you and Rob Pattinson had broken up sure
was there a point you would have gotten
married do you think I wanted to yeah no
I mean like I think I've never been
posed you would have been you would have
gotten married I don't know I'm not a
super-duper traditionalist but at the
same time I like yeah everything I've
ever every relationship I've ever been
in I thought that's it I've never liked
casually I mean maybe one or two
everyone that do but like I've never
really been the most casual person you
know do you think you'll get married one
day yeah for sure
that appeals to you like it never did
Anne yes absolutely now it does yeah
absolutely and in no way that's tied to
like any weird sort of convention it's
more just like I when you know you know
you know I mean I recommend marriage
mm-hmm I think it says to people this is
the person I hold above all others
that's how I feel too and I want to
announce that to the world
there is nothing like feeling sure about
anything because we don't know anything
and that is the only thing you can feel
like you know is that if you're in love
with someone and it elevates I don't
know what it is about that tradition it
elevates the relationship beyond what
you could have imagined I completely
agree with you it's romantic
yeah and it's I don't care about like
who is being recognized but not in a way
that's like I don't feel like I'm kowtow
to a sort of patriarchal standard I
don't fit but I do feel like I want to
like that honoring that and having other
people recognize it [ __ ] the government
but just people and your your family
that means a lot to me